el cirujano le insertará un marcapasos
en el cuerpo si el sistema de conducción
del corazón el sistema eléctrico que
hace latir el corazón no está
funcionando adecuadamente el corazón es
un órgano muscular con cuatro cámaras
la sangre se acumula en las dos cámaras
superiores o atrio antes de llenar las
dos cámaras inferiores o ventrículos
cuando los ventrículos se contraen la
sangre del ventrículo derecho es
bombeada a los pulmones y la sangre del
ventrículo izquierdo es bombeada al
resto del cuerpo el corazón de un
marcapasos natural llamado nódulo sino
auricular o nódulo s/a el marcapasos
controla la frecuencia cardíaca
determinando precisamente cuando los
músculos del atrio y los ventrículos se
contraen la señal eléctrica producida
por el nódulo s/a
llega a los ventrículos a través de un
camino estrecho que incluye el conocido
nódulo ave y las ramas fascículos
consideradas todas juntas se hace
referencia a estas vías como el sistema
de conducción del corazón
los problemas con el sistema de
conducción se pueden producir si el
nódulo s/a funcionen correctamente y
hace que el corazón lata demasiado
rápido demasiado lento o irregularmente
como alternativa se puede producir un
bloqueo en las ramas particulares
haciendo que el corazón lata más
lentamente o irregularmente estos
problemas pueden ser la consecuencia de
una enfermedad cardíaca medicamentos o
cirugía cardíaca antes del procedimiento
se evalúan la sangre y la orina también
se le tomaran radiografías del pecho y
se le realizará un electrocardiograma o
encaje que registrará la actividad
eléctrica del corazón
se le inyectará anestesia local en la
piel para adormecer el área donde se
insertará el marcapasos
el cirujano realizará una pequeña
incisión por debajo de la clavícula los
catéteres del marcapasos serán
insertados en la vena subclavia y luego
deslizados hacia el corazón hasta llegar
al atrio derecho
el cirujano observará las imágenes de
rayos x en una pantalla de vídeo para
ubicar los catéteres correctamente una
vez evaluados los catéteres serán
conectados al generador de pulso luego
el generador de pulso será ubicado en
una pequeña bolsa que el cirujano creará
de manera subcutánea debajo de la
clavícula y luego el cirujano coser a la
incisión mientras esté en el hospital el
médico controlará la frecuencia cardíaca
y la presión arterial para asegurarse de
que el marcapasos está funcionando
correctamente antes de partir el médico
le hará los ajustes finales a la
configuración del marcapasos
posteriormente al procedimiento los
medicamentos de venta libre para el
dolor como acetaminofeno o ibuprofeno
deberán ser suficientes para aliviar
cualquier dolor no podrá manejar durante
dos semanas aproximadamente
periódicamente deberás realizar un
seguimiento con el médico para evaluar y
ajustar el nuevo marcapasos